hey reject nation happy Sunday how you
doing
we're gonna watch Gotham trailer not
jerome jeremiah white band trailer sir
season 4 gonna give a bit of an intro
here the last time we did a reaction in
this I said I think I should just start
the show again as I only saw like the
first episode a couple years ago I
started this show again just a couple
weeks ago and I'm on Episode five now I
really am enjoying the hell out of this
series we do TV show reaction watch
alongs on our patreon I've just been
watching this on my own I'm thinking of
possibly just continuing it by doing
watch alongs on our patreon and I was
like [ __ ] I avoid this should I avoid
this because you know I'm not caught up
to date with it I'm actually really into
the show right now no one seems to care
every video we put out anything we
talked about what are you going to check
this trailer out did I figure why not
I'll still check it out and plus I
thought about it don't really remember a
hell of a lot of the other trailers for
Gotham because I haven't been following
the shows this is so many episodes ahead
that by the time I get to this point I
might even forget some stuff that I see
in this trailer so I'm just gonna watch
it the one time really check it out
probably gonna do patron reaction watch
along
you know could go insane just one day I
just want to paint the trees I can't
wait to get to this part of the show
proficiency for maths and design and
draw mainly the mutilation of alley cats
it hit me a way to protect me from them
but I knew one day Jerome would come for
me you all couldn't I can this actor is
so talented
Oh No
so see the one who becomes the joke
[Music]
that time to give Gotham City its new
face the city just like the one that
killed Jenny Gordon you're more sick
thing and father we just wanted to
destroy things I'm the Builder what
every understands a blank canvas
I know seeing is believing cool
with Mike or relay in his hand and a
grenade taped to his mouth
indeed it is it seems you have the upper
hand something one welding Avenue be
there in an hour or tell the police no
no no no Alfred
[Music]
wander on them it could be
[ __ ] city fun
[Music]
laughing matter
ouch wow man this was Cameron Monaghan
guy he can act and I've only seen scenes
and tracers I haven't even seen like a
full episode with this guy yet how cool
for him getting to do not only Georgia
Rome but Jeremiah yeah now like two
completely different characters cut off
the same block
I haven't spoiled myself enough yet to
know if they ever labeled Jerome as the
Joker all right I don't know for him to
do like two different iterations of this
guy is awesome so cool people already
love what he does and from the looks of
it looks like in season three he died
but in season four I mean they're doing
like the haha' and everything so this
must be leading up to the definitive
type of Joker that will carry on through
the show when Bruce Wayne does become
Batman and I'm excited it's like was
that spoiled for me yeah but in a weird
way I'm not actually upset about it it's
easier knowing that that wasn't the
Joker yeah yeah yeah when it comes to a
TV show like this - you know it's a
prequel show - the Batman story and it's
more than just that but this is one of
those shows it's so about the journey
the plot points are of course important
but something like that is it's a plot
point I could get past in the spoiler
way and go yeah I get past that and just
get on board with the journey right now
I am really enjoying the show and this
is the first time watching want to do it
much when these trailers where I'm going
I can't with this one and the one before
it have made me want to check out this
yeah cuz it seems like when people start
raving about the shows when Jerome came
in the fact that I'm already really
liking the show and a lot of people have
told me Susan Wood's kind of we've
seasoned Susan when it gets great and
the fact that I'm only I never suffice
season one going I'm actually really
enjoying the hell out of it I'm just
even that much more excited to get to
this Dark Dimension point of this series
oh yeah one I mean Batman's villains are
so much funny you get that scene those
that montage later on the trailer where
you see like a bunch of them in quick
flashes in heaven so not only do you get
the promise of how cool
Jeremiah is gonna be but also like the
interaction between him and whoever else
of Gotham's villains I don't know if I
saw that right but was that a bat mask
going on in one closer look like a
prototype thing that he was working on
you know like the early stages of kind
of like in Batman Begins when he had
just like the ski mask on and like the
dark clothes on so maybe that was the
prototype section of it I'm hoping that
I like Bruce Wayne more because I'm only
on Episode five and I'm like I can't
really like this Bruce Wayne dude I feel
like everyone else is so much more
interesting well I feel like it's tricky
when you cast a kid like it's a cool
idea to have child Bruce Wayne and to
watch him grow up but like you got to
hope that that kid grows up a good actor
yeah I just think the writing of him is
lackluster currently keep in mind I'm
only on season 1 right now this just
gets me more excited to keep continuing
this show and I'm probably gonna do
watch the long as I'm paid ramaa I'm
wondering if I should just finish the
first season and start doing watch along
this when we get to season 2 don't you
guys let me know put it in the comment
boxes see if maybe I'll just start it up
now anyway thanks to everyone for not
giving feedback on any of our videos and
just saying to react to this appreciate
that really hopefully you guys can
subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification belt that subscribe
buttons do not work and check us on
patreon fold line TV show reactions
weekly Q&A s music video reactions
patron requests a whole bunch of goodies
go check it out
you